Foreign
[Music]
활성 라이브 스트림 번호 50.0에 오신 것을 환영합니다.
2022년 10월 17일이며 제어로
allostasis를 모델링하는 interoception에 대한 시리즈를 시작하고 있습니다
. active inference Institute에 오신 것을 환영합니다.
우리는
학습과 소통을 하는 참여형 온라인 연구소입니다
적용된 능동 추론 연습
이것은 아카이브 라이브 스트림에 기록
되므로 작업을 개선할 수 있도록 피드백을 제공하십시오.
모든 배경과 관점을
환영하며 오늘 50.0에서
라이브 스트림에 대한 좋은 비디오 에티켓을
따를 것입니다. 우리는 이 시리즈에
대해 논의하기 시작합니다.  제어로 allostasis를 모델링하는 논문 가로채기
저자는 Eli synesh
Jordanrialt Dana Brooks John wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett 및 Karen s
Quigley
입니다. 2022년 1월 생물학적 심리학 저널에 발표된 논문
이며 이것은 단지 소개 및
맥락입니다.  여기에서 Dean으로 비디오를 촬영하고
이 문서를 통해 작업하고 몇 가지
관련 주제에 대해 논의합니다.
몇 가지 큰
질문에 대한 기본 목표와 논문의 추상적인
로드맵을 살펴보고 몇 가지 핵심 요점과
이미지 및 주제를 다룬 다음 주로
저자 또는 원하는 다른 사람과 논의하기를 기대합니다.
앞으로 몇 주 안에 합류
할 수 있습니다. 저는 Daniel입니다. 저는
캘리포니아의 연구원이고
그 논문은
탈중앙화 찬성 투표
에 의해 선택되었습니다. 재미있게 읽었고
우리 관심 영역에 새로운 주제를 가져오기
때문에 찾고 있습니다.  앞으로는 Dean에게 전달하겠습니다.
감사합니다 Charlie 저는 Dean입니다. 저는 여기
캘거리
에 있습니다. 겉보기에 신중하지 않은 것처럼 보이는 것을 끌어당겨
근위부를 배치
하고 얽히게 한 다음
다시 떼어내는 종이의 흥미로운 점은 무엇입니까?
모든 것이 결합될 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 살펴보려고 합니다.
항상 제가 항상
관심을 갖고 있는 부분입니다. 사실 이것이 바로
이것의 제목이었고
,
알로스타시스와 테레셉션을 함께 가져오고 무엇을 했는지에 대한 사실이었습니다.  s
그 의미는 내가
이것에 대해 약간의 시간을 보낸 이유였고 정말로
나는
저자들이
이 아이디어를
올바르게 작동시켰기 때문에 저자가 말하는 것을 듣는 데 매우 흥미가 있습니다.
여기서 초점
은 무슨 일이 일어나고 생리학적 작업을 수행하는
데 필요한 컨트롤러 요구 사항에 대해 말할 수 있는지에 초점을 맞추고 있다고 생각
합니다. 다양한
정도의 복잡성
음
저는
다양한 결과와 행동의 특이성이
종합적으로 어떻게 보이는지 전혀 확신하지 못했지만
우리가 말할 수 있는 것 중
하나는 예측 구성요소
가 있고 피드백 구성요소가
있고 그들이 그 두 가지 특정 유형에 초점을 맞추고
있다는 것입니다.
음, 아마도 우리가 어떤 종류의
일반성을
무시할 수 있는지 알 수 없습니다.
우물의 잡초에 헤매지 않고
여기 저기서 일어난 일
이지만 일반적인 수준에서
그 두 가지를 합치면 어떤 종류의 일입니까?
음 우리가 특정 패턴이나
공통성을
좋게 말해야합니까? 나는 그것을 생리학의
예측적 변화
이며 도메인
또는 차단과 같은 사용 사례와 연결되는 항상성(alostasis)과 같은 주어진 시스템 독립 또는 양식 독립 현상을 묻는 범주에 넣을 것이라는 데 동의합니다.  그리고 우리
가 탐구한 많은 모델
이 시각적이거나
개념적이거나
상징적이며 차단 양식이
토론에서 계속해서 등장한 것
같습니다. 따라서 차단을 위한 형식주의를 살펴볼 수 있는 멋진 기회입니다.
좋습니다.
앞서 설명한 바와 같이 논문 간행물 페이지
에서 저자가 작성한 몇 가지 하이라이트
차단 뇌
는 신체의 다가오는 신진대사
요구를 예측할 수 있습니다 차단
내장 운동 조절에 대한 성능 지표 제공
우리는 제어 이론을 의사
결정 및 운동 제어와 연결합니다  신체의
우리
는 시간에 따른 최적의 제어가 다양하므로 allostatic 제어를 모델링합니다.  참조
신호를 통해
그들은
이전 모델의 몇 가지 제한 사항과
해당 모델이 수행하는 작업의 몇 가지 고유한 측면
및 추가할 사항이 없는 apic 모델을 공식화하는 방식에 대해 이야기합니다.
클레임 조정자 평가자
심사관 및 조사관
의 관점에서 우리
는 이 비교적
길고 기술적으로 비계된 논문의 주장 내에서 매우 중요하고 두드러진 몇 가지
를 뽑아내고 점과 집합을 연결하는 많은 주장을 뽑아냈습니다.
형식주의에 대한 관련 어 해석 중 일부
를 강조 표시하고 싶습니까 아니면 이것
에 동의하고 싶은 사람을 위해 그것들을
갖는 것이 좋습니다. 그러나 여기서 이것을 말할 것입니다.
여기
예측
예측 어 처리 사이 아니요
예측 처리를 말하는 것이
아니라 예측 장치로 처리
그리고 감정
, 통제, 피드백
등 많은 주장이 있을 수 있다고 생각합니다
.
하지만 그것은 정말
음미한 뉘앙스와 매우
복잡한
어 공간을 가지고 놀기 때문에 음이 많은 이유를 이해할 수 있습니다.
그
주장이 무너지기 전에 그 주장이 얼마나 유지
될 수 있는지에
대해 다시 한번
주장합니다  나는 머리카락이 많아서 그것은
나에게 까다 롭습니다.
모든 권리
추상
좋습니다. 처음 세 가지를 읽을 것입니다
. 뇌는 신체
의 필요를 예측하고 신체의 요구 사항
이 발생하기 전에 충족하려고 시도함으로써 신체를 조절합니다.
allostasis allostasis는
신체 내 감각 조건의 변화 이 백서에서 차단이라고 하는 과정
우리는 상호 수용이 어떻게 알로스타시스에
대한 성능 피드백을 제공할 수 있는지 조사합니다
우리는 테에서 알로스타시스를 연구할 것을 제안합니다
제어 이론의 rms 제어
이론 검토 생리학의 관련 문제에 대한 적용
운동 제어 및 의사 결정
우리는 제어 문제로서 발기부전 조절의 중요한 속성과 연관시켜 이것들을 종합합니다.
그런 다음 우리
는 뇌가 동종 조절을 수행할 수 있는 방법에 대한 정상적인 형식을 스케치합니다.
내장을 유추
하여 수학적 관점을 포함하는 두 개의 골격 운동 제어
및 교차가
항상성에 대한 성능 피드백으로 작용
하는 방법 마지막으로 우리는 로드맵에 우리 가설의 의미를 테스트하는 방법을 제안합니다. 좋습니다.
생리학 운동 제어
의사 결정
과 알로스타시스를 궤도
추적 확률론적 최적
제어로 통합하기 위한 접근으로 차단 제어 이론인 합성 및 해석의 핵심 기둥 또는 기초를 소개합니다. 다섯 번째 섹션은 토론
이고 부록 B가 있습니다.
시  nd 그들의 말로 이 논문의 4개 섹션은
차단을 알로스타시스에
연결합니다 섹션 2
는 상호 수용이 뇌가 현재 순간
에 신체의 생리학적 효율성을 추정할 수 있도록 하는 방법을 설정합니다.
이론
섹션 4에서는 제어 이론의 원리를 적용
하여 뇌
가 생리적 궤적의 바람직함을 추정하고
예상
규제 결정을 내리는 방법에 대한 새로운 형식 모델을 도출합니다. 섹션 5
에서는 제안된 형식주의 부록의 직접적인 의미를 탐구하기 위해 앞의 세 섹션을 종합합니다.
용어집을 제공하지만 이것은
위로 이동되고 더 이상 부록이 아니므로 부록
이 없습니다.
부록 B1
은 섹션 3과 관련된
수학적
세부 정보를 제공하고 부록 C1은 섹션 4와 관련된 수학적 세부 정보를 제공
합니다. 키워드는 차단
알로스타시스 및 예측
처리였습니다.  간다  이 점 0에서 차단과 항상성에 대해 많은 이야기를
나누지
만
확실히 앞으로의 토론과
예측 처리에서 좋은 최근
스트림은 Maria와 함께하는 라이브 스트림 번호 43
입니다. 좋습니다.
스크린샷을 원할 경우
많은 단어의 정의가 있는 명명법 테이블이 있으므로
여기에 첫 번째 명명법 용어 1
에서 25가 있습니다.
그리고 여기에
명명법의 후반부가 있습니다. 26에서 49까지입니다.
그들이 그것을 제공했다는 것이 좋고
다음 섹션에서 잘 사용될 것이라고 말하는 것은
그들이 뽑은 음
이 정의를 앞으로 끌어 냈다는 것을 지적한 것이 흥미 롭다고 생각합니다. 그런 다음
형식을 볼 때 그렇게
생각합니다.  그들이 이 꼬임에
관해 메시지를 주고자 하는 것의 관점에서 볼 때
우리는 적어도 이전에
의미하는 바에 대해 상식을 알아야 합니다.
우리는
그것들이 동등한 것을 분리하려고 노력하기 시작합니다.
그래서 예, 제가 그런 종류의
좋은 말
을 했습니다. 좋습니다. 섹션 1 소개
신체에서 뇌의 기능을 소개합니다
. 알겠습니다. 이 문서의 시작 부분이 연상되는 부분이 있습니다.
음 간단한 피구 게임
을 하고 있습니다  두뇌가
신체의 시스템을 지속적으로 조정해야
하며 이 피구의 모티브는 다시 돌아올
것이고 왼쪽은 포옹하는 얼굴
입니다. 안정적인 확산
알고리즘의 구현 이미지의 프롬프트는
DodgeBall이었습니다 장난기 많은 개미 능동적인 추론
자유 에너지 원리
슬라이드를 만드는 동안 우리
는 이러한 이미지 생성
어포던스를 사용하여 능동적인 추론에 참여했고 그것이 잘 할 수 있도록 했습니다.
제 생각에
이것이 생성자가 말한
것이 조정된 음의 결과일 것이라는 것이 정말 흥미롭다고 생각합니다
.  나는
이러한 프롬프트의 얽힘을 찾고
있지만 각각이 어떤 전략을 가지고 있는지에 대해서는 아무 말도 하지 않았습니다.
그
음 실루엣이 지금 사용
하고 있고 전략이 진행되고 있다는 암시적인 감각이 있다고 생각합니다.
그래서
정말 흥미로운 것들을 함께 가져갈 때
음 그것은 얼마나 깊이 가고 싶은지에 달려 있다고 생각합니다
당신
은 공간을 차원화하기를 원
하므로 바로 거기에 있는 것이 무엇입니까? 예
이것은 동일한 프롬프트입니다. 이것은 또 다른 하나였습니다.
이것은
조금 더 사실적이며
이해하기 어려운 것처럼 보입니다. 그들이 피구를 하고 있는지
예,
그들은 단지 추측하고 있는 것뿐입니다.
다음 키워드
사람들이 여기에서 정의를 읽을 수만 있다면 선택할 수
있지만
가로채기가
무엇인지 스스로 판단하십시오.  때때로 젊은 사람들
이나 모든 사람들
이 감정의 우산 아래 그들을 모두 분류
하고 어
항상 t에서 일했기 때문에 tots On Target에서 이것을 가져 왔습니다.
우리가 이것을 가능한 한 간단하게 유지하는 방법에 대한 일종의 공간입니다.
따라서 이러한 신호를 받을 때
이러한 감각 신호
는 신체 내부에서 발생하는 것이며, 이러한 감각 신호는
당신이 느끼는 감정이며
어 당신이 그것을 외부 세계와 연결하는지 여부에 관계없이
피부나 여백
음 가끔 하기도 하고 하지도
않고 그냥 잠에서 깨어나 배가
아파서 그래 그게 오늘에 대해 의미하는 바는 무엇인가?
그것은
신체 외부의 X 타로와 대조적으로 신체 내부의 타로에 있습니다.
그러나 아마도
흐릿함과 같은 것이 많이 있을 수
있으며 망막이 실제로 하는 일은
자체
에 대한 추론을 수행하고 외부 세계 구조에 대한 추론을 실제로 수행하는 위치는 어디입니까?
올바른 인터셉트
내부 모델 몇 가지 이미지를 추가했습니다. 그래서 이미지가
무엇입니까
그래서
심리학자
들이 여러 용어에 의한 인터셉션을 포함하여 내부 모드를 참조하도록 빨리 읽을 것입니다.
내부 모델이 무엇인지 명확하게 정의하는 것에 대해 항상 동의하지 않았기 때문에 그것이 중요하다고 생각합니다.
음 무의식적 관심과 같은 것들이
이 우산 구현 시뮬레이션에 맞는 것 같습니다
개념과 범주
는 환각을 제어했는데
이는 저에게 새로운 것이었습니다.  그것이 무엇을 의미하는지 알지 못합니다.
어 그리고 그것이 무엇인지에 관계없이
뇌는 세계에서
신체의 동적 모델을 구성하는 것으로 가정합니다
이 논문에서는 예측 시뮬레이션 및 개념이라는 용어를 사용합니다.
납치의 관점에서 신호는 대상을 해석
했습니다
음 그 모델은 무엇입니까 그것이
재현되고 내용이 채워져
있는지 또는
우리가
느끼는 것이 있는지에 대한 또 다른 큰 논쟁에 빠지지 않도록 하는 방법 매 시간마다 내부에서
단일 시간 데이터가 우리에게 와서
우리의 다른 감각 표면에 쏟아지고
있습니다. 외부 외부 외부
방 안의 온도가 올라가면 외부에서 오는 조각이 있는 것 같은데, 내 몸
도
못된 새우를 먹어서 온도가 올라갈 수도 있고
가끔 더위가 나간 탓인지 분간이 어려울 때가 있다.
또는 내 몸이 염증 제스처로 반응하는지 여부
예
,
차이를 만드는 원인 또는 차이
를 만드는 차이라고 하는 것과 같은 좋은 점
입니다.  바이러스
대 이것 면역 체계의 역학 변화
그래서
흥미로운 왼쪽 이미지는 알고
있습니다 왼쪽 이미지 왼쪽
이미지 오른쪽 이미지가 실제로
도로를 따라 이동하는 속도가 얼마인지 알 수 없습니다
그것이 바로 우리가 실제로 무엇을 설명하고 추구할 수 있는지에 대해 demacio가 많이 이야기한다는 것을 알고 있기 때문에 내가 장수용기 모델에 대한 모호성을 원했던 이유입니다.
간결한 용어
와 다소 모호한 부분
이 있으며 이 백서의 저자는
신에 대해서도 조금 이야기합니다. 예 대상
이 외부적일 때 객관적인 경우
여러 외부
관점이 일치할 기회
가 있습니다.  일부 생리학적 조절에 대한 생리적 설정점의 구체화된 행동
이 변경되면 더 나은
외부 정렬을 위한 동일한 기회가 다시 주어지지 않고
더 나
빠지며 거의 항상
의사소통이 어렵거나
실험실 설정 및 견적
제어에서 측정하는 데 어려움이 있습니다.  저자와 이것에 대해 이야기하고
그들이 이 양식을 연구하는 이유
는 매우 흥미로울 것입니다. 교차점에서 Alice와 통합하려고 하는
계산 또는
시스템 독립 현상
에 대해서는 알로스타시스
라는 용어를 알로스타시스로 정의합니다.
변화하는
요구는 우선 순위를 평가하고 조직을
준비  sm
오류가 발생하기 전에 이를 만족시키기 위해 allostasis라고 하는 프로세스가
있으므로 방의 온도
에 대한 allostatic 모델이
있고 핵심 체온은
변하지 않으므로 되돌아보고 그렇지 않다고 말할 수 있다고 가정해 보겠습니다.
변화가 예상
되고 누군가가 잘 말할
것이기 때문에
체온을 올리지 않았기 때문에 효과
가 있다는 것을 어떻게
알았
습니까?  항상 여기서 최소값이 무엇인지에 대해 이야기
합니다. 이를 수행하기 위해 필요한 최소값은 무엇
입니까
? 왜 3
개가 아닌 4개 또는 5개가
더 작은 조각으로 쪼개지는지 그 중 하나인 더 작은 조각으로 나누는 것이 정말 흥미롭지 않습니다.
질문
저자가 작성한
모든 올바른 능동
추론에 대해 이야기하고 싶습니다. 정식 모델링 세부 사항에 대해 자세히 알아보기
여기 있는 접근 방식
을 저명한 모델링 프레임워크
능동 추론과 비교 및 ​​대조
하고 이러한 세부 사항 중 일부로 돌아가서 이에
대해 많은 논의가 있을
것이라고 확신하지만 어떻게  그들은
그들의 모델을
다운스트림으로 취급하거나
우리가 자유 에너지 원리 기본적으로 역학에 대해 자주 듣는 특정 물리학에 대한 약속의 결과
로 취급하지 않고 오히려
모델
을 추가하려는 모든 것을 1차 구성으로 취급하고 있습니다.  그것이
내가 논문의 내용을 구성하는 데 도움이 된다고 생각했기 때문에
그래 그게 스트리트 부분이라고 생각하기
때문에 문헌에서 가장 적극적인 관심 모델과 달리 작업 글머리 기호는
무기한 또는 무한한 Horizon 제어 설정을 고려한 아래 자료
가 흥미롭기 때문에  그것은
그들이
말하는 것과 t0인 많은 표현에서 우리가 자주 보는 것 사이를 정말 명확하게 만듭니다.
T1에서 T까지
어떤
일이 순차적으로 진행되고 있는지 알아낼 수 있다는 점
에서 서두의 이 섹션은
다른 모델과 관련된 몇 가지 문제
에 대해 이야기하고 기존 차단 모델이 어떻게 전향적 결정으로 allostasis를 공식화했는지에 대해 이야기합니다.
다양한 해석이 있지만 예를
들어
정책을 열거한 다음 정책에서 선택
하거나 운동 명령이 다른 문제에서 비롯된 위치를 고려하지 않은 운동 제어 문제와 같이 이러한 결정이 어떻게 제정되는지 고려하지 않고 문제 만들기
모델은 대사
효율성을 목표로 다루기보다는 항상성을 논의하고 오류에 대한
고정된 허용 오차로 설정값을 수정하기 위한 신체 변수의 조절을 논의
하므로
설정값 및
가변성을 수정하기보다는 실제로 멋진 주제가 될 것입니다.  attra
를 초래하는 다른 프로세스로 인한 것입니다.
고정된 설정
값과 오류에 대한 경험적 허용 오차 및
일부 반환되지 않는 지점
등으로 설정 또는 점을 지정
하지만 이러한 모든 결과를
실제로 설정값을 추구하지 않고 오히려 오히려 추구하는 동적 시스템의 실현으로 보는
것
우리가 탐색할 그래프의 기울기를 추구하고 진화 시간에 따라
최대 제어 가능성 영역 및 최대 제어 가능성 영역 주변의 놀라움 감소는
이러한 종류의 생존
변수
와 연관될 것이며 일부 다른 점은 괜찮습니다.
글쎄, 그것은 관계 관계
관계이고 그들은 이
논문이 이 간극을 채우는 것을 목표로 한다고 말합니다
내 생각에 관계
에서 무언가를 채워서 간극이 무엇이든 관계가 반드시 닫혀야
한다는 것을 의미하지는 않습니다  타겟팅에 대해 이야기합니다.
저는
그들이 여기에서 일어나고 있다고 생각하는 일에서 관계가 일종의 핵심 역할을 한다고 생각한다는 사실에 대해 생각
합니다.
음 의미  그들은 어쩌면 격차가
계속될지도 모른다고 내 말은 그들이
우리가 고려하고 숙고하기 위해 여기에 물건을 넣고 있다는 것을 의미
하지만
우리가 실제로
이 안에 무엇이 있는지 이해하는 간격을 채우고 있는지 확실하지 않습니다.
space
right
section 2 so section 2의 시작 부분에
있는 상단
문단 가로채기 모델링
의 효율성을 추정한
다음 접힌 부분 아래에
섹션 2.5 요약 그래서 이들 모두
pre와 post 2.
um 2.0
2.2
에 대한 구조적 정보가 많이 포함되어 있습니다.
이 문서의 요점은
이 특정 슬라이드에 추가할 내용이
아니면
맨 아래에 있는 별표 섹션으로 이동하여
사람들이 읽고 싶어할 수도 있습니다.
용량 곡선의 응답 범위를 향한 움직임
이 잠재적
으로 전용 신경 회로나 모듈
이 필요하지 않게 할 수 있다는 점이 흥미롭습니다.
보상 비용의 행동 구조
그래서 생리학에
대한 비보상 중심적
이해로 이동한다는 것은 무엇을 의미합니까
또는 보상을 재해석
하는 것이 좋습니다 섹션 2.1은 두 유형의 차이인 나머지 문서에서 핵심이 될 구별을 소개합니다
내장
감각 변수의 가로
채기 자원의 양을 나타내는 것
조절된 자원과 프로세스가 작동
하는 속도를 나타내는 것
조절된 과정
조절된 자원은
시간이 지남에 따라 상대적으로 안정적으로 유지됩니다 예를
들어 혈당과 심부 체온을 포함
하므로 주의할 점은
고갈 자원
이 되려면 규제 자원
은 항상성 맥락에서 생리학의 경계 변수와 같습니다. 반드시
그런 것은 아닙니다
대사 산물
과 같은 고갈 자원 uh 혈당 또는 코어 체온과 같은 규제 자원은
물리량 또는 포도당과 같은 물질을 나타냅니다.
순간적으로 변할 수 없기 때문에  다른 양식의 다른 규제 자원이 무엇인지 묻는 것이 흥미로울 것이라고 생각합니다.
그러면 통제된 과정
은 생리적
과정이 작동하는 속도이므로 혈당
의 입력 출력 관계와 같을 것입니다.
최근에 우리가 이야기한
그리퍼와 그립의 차이점은 무엇이며
둘 다 동시에 존재할 수
있다는 점입니다.
운동을 시작하고 휴식 상태에서 운동을 계속하기 위해서는 약간의 생리학적 적응이 필요합니다.
압력 수용체인 압력 수용체 심박수
반사는 일반적으로 심장 박동
을 늦춤으로써 혈압 상승에 대응
하지만, 운동을 하면
혈압과 심박수가 모두
증가하여 지지력을 유지해야 합니다.  전 애인이
필요로 하는 혈류량 증가
근육을 운동
하고 그런 다음
이러한 종류의 반사 조절이 어떻게 혈압의 변화와
심박수의 변화와 관련된 전체 기능의 전환을 허용하는지에
대한 논의가 있습니다.  다양한 생리적 변수의 인과적 또는 상관적
구조가 어떻게
꽤 일반적으로 모델링될 수 있지만 더 구체적이 될 것입니다.
예, 거기에 약간의 공변량
, 어
, 생리학 그리고 우리는
괜찮습니다. 2.2
규제되고 제어되는 프로세스의 범위를 예측하고 모델링
합니다.  곡선의 일부 매개변수를 설명하고
부분적으로 파생되는 임계값과 포화
점 생리학자가
섭동과 조절
반응 사이의 연결을 모델링하는 데 일반적으로 사용
하는 기능에서 파생된 곡선을 정의합니다.  곡선은
강조하는 데 사용됩니다.  e
그러한 곡선은 시간이 지남
에 따라 어느 한 순간에 이동할 수 있지만 유기체가 사용할 수 있는
제한된 규제 자원의 현재 범위를 나타내
므로
어떤 지점에서 시장을 유지하기 위한 재정 능력 곡선
처럼 상상할 수 있습니다.
그러나
유추
에 따르면 시스템이 섭동에
어떻게 반응하는지 모델링하는 이 아이디어는
반드시
해당 시스템의 내부 모델을 모델링할 필요는 없지만
더 나은 실험보다 섭동 중인 시스템의 더 나은 생성 모델을 구축함
에 따라 더 멀리 할 수 ​​있습니다.  어
시스템의 일종의 섭동이 있어 시스템의 구조
에 대한 강력한 가설 없이 시스템에 접근할 수 있습니다
. 그림 2의 용량 곡선
또는 그림 1의 수학적
형식이 있고 그림 1이
방정식 1과 함께
매개변수는 다음과 같습니다.  정의된 함수
y는 U mu K를 R Big B로 취하여
이들을 방정식으로 결합하는
것입니다.  x축은
혈압
을 나타내고 y축은 이 생리적 변수를 조절
하는 반사의 기준선 활성화 백분율을 보여줍니다.
따라서 100에서 목표
혈압 또는 일종의
항상성 설정점이라고
하는 것입니다.  그 지점에서 어트랙터인 것 같습니다
. 배럴 반사의 Baseline 활성화
는 혈압이 증가할 때 발생
하고 배럴 반사
는 Baseline의 2x 활성화에서 최대 2x 임계값까지 활성화
한 다음 혈압이
감소함에 따라 이 S자형으로 배럴 반사를 다시 활성화합니다.
대칭 감소
는 혈압
방정식 2 3 및 4의 동적 조절 모델입니다
. 생성 모델의 형태를 개략적으로 설명합니다. 관찰되지 않은
변수의 관점에서 관찰된 변수를 확률적으로 예측하는 절차
나열된
변수는 A Priory 확률에서 샘플링된 관찰되지 않은 변수입니다.
데이터에 의존하지 않는 분포
는 생성기를 사용하는 것을
의미합니다.  ive 모델 및 이러한 방정식이 구성하는 방법
여기 제안에는 X에 대한 방정식이 일반적이지 않은 특징
이 있습니다.
그리고 왜 배럴 반사
활성화가 기준선의 백분율로 표시
되어 그림 1 X 및 Y
또는 분위수 변수 U의 관점에서 볼 수 있습니까?
분위수 변수
는 용량 곡선의 작동 점 mu
및 게인 K의 변화에 ​​관계없이 혈압과 배럴 반사 활성화 간의 관계를 균일하게 나타냅니다. 분위수
는 용량 곡선의 기능적 형태
에만 의존하고 매개변수에는 의존하지 않으므로
포장을 풉니다.  기술적으로는 조금 더 기술적으로 설명
하지만 나중에 논의할 공간이 더
많은 그림 1이 더 큰
그림
1과 주황색의 선형 응답과 함께 파란색으로 표시된 그림 1의 용량 곡선인 그림 2가 있습니다.
이 S자형 곡선의 최대 양의 기울기로 볼 수 있도록 작동점 주변에 Blue Diamond 마커
반사가 S자형 방식으로 활성화된다는 사양에
따라 커브가 올라가는 부분과 아래로 굽는 부분 중 어느 부분에 있는지
또는
최대 양의 기울기
를 추구한다고 생각하는지에 따라 그 지점을 추적하고
보상을 받습니다.  최대의
기동성과 제어
를 향한 움직임은
이것이 고정 포인트 어트랙터와 같은 항상성 모델을 추구하는 것과 동일
하므로
이 오렌지 라인
에서 블루 다이아몬드가 감소하는 것보다 경사
에서 최대화되는 그릇 바닥의 종류를 넣습니다.  100에서 그 거리
그리고 이산화탄소
다음으로 우리는 조절된 자원으로서 혈당에 초점을 맞추고
글루카곤을
분비를 가능하게 하는 조절된 과정으로 사용합니다.
혈당과 인슐린은 혈액
에서 포도당 제거를 가능하게 하는 제어 과정으로서
배럴
반사는 단일 볼륨 노브
또는 단일 반응을 낮추거나 높일 수 있는 분류 간호사
와 같았습니다. 따라서 일부 생리학적 변수가 높으면 그렇게
할 수 있습니다.  제거된
포도당 조절에는 여러 호르몬
이 있습니다
. 약간 다른 방식으로 서로 다른 두 측면에서 완충되는 것과 같을
것입니다. 그러나 동일한
형식과 논리
를 많이 사용하여 약간
다르고 복잡한 생리학적
시스템을 도입합니다.
혈당 수치가
생물학적으로
하드 코딩된 설정점에서 능동적으로 방어되지 않는다는 사실은 심장
박동수가 대신 글루카곤과 인슐린이라는 두 가지
호르몬
활동이 서로의 효과를 균형 있게 조정
하여 혈당을 혈당
이 안정 범위
내로 들어가게 하는 것입니다.
사람이 음식과 포도당을
섭취한 후 혈액에서 다른
신체로 이동  기능을 지원하는 조직
이 슬라이드에 추가할 사항은
특별히 없습니다. 이제
섹션이 끝날 때까지 기다리지 않습니다. 두 번째 두 가지 항목이
있으므로 여기에
그림 3을 작성
하고 있습니다.
용량 곡선으로 해석할 수 있는 인슐린 경우
주황색 S자형은
인슐린 파란색 S자형은 글루카곤
혈액 내 포도당 수준인 다른 x축에서 호르몬 수준이 다르기 때문에
포도당이 높을 때 익숙한 행동을 볼 수 있습니다.
그런 다음 인슐린
은 포도당의 흡수를 유도하는 고분비
상태이며 이 경우 포도당이
2.5 또는 3 이하로 낮아지면
글루카곤이 분비되어 포도당
이 혈액으로
들어가도록 유도합니다. 따라서 포도당 수준이 진동할 것이라고 상상할 수 있습니다
이 공간에
있지만
잔류가 최소화되는 설정점에서 정확히 설정되지 않은
섹션 2.4
는 이러한 종류의 규제에 대한 논의에서 이동하는 곳
입니다.
실행 가능한 범위와 능력
으로 모듈식 보상 시스템을 피할 수
있음 신경 해부학에 대한 논쟁
또는 호소
차단의 영역 일반성은
우리가 정신 모듈이나 교수진이 필요하지 않다는 아이디어에 대한 이론적 지원을 추가로 제공합니다
심리학
뇌가 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하기 위한 개념
allostatic 제어에 대한 수학적으로 건전하고 생물학적으로 그럴듯한 설명은
중앙에서 모듈식 또는 별도의 보상 시스템을 필요로 하지 않습니다  신경계
및 이 주제에 대해 조금 더 추가할 사항이 있으면
이제 37로 가겠습니다.
좋습니다. 제어의 보상입니다. 그래서 여기
에서는 Tobias Norville이 관련된 두 논문의 멋진 이미지가 있는 두 논문을 강조
하고 싶었고 이 논문은 논문에서 인용되었습니다.
토론 중이며 모두
꽤 관심을 보입니다.  휴식 기능이므로
이 그래프 중 일부를 강조 표시하기 위해
여기에 포도당
및 온도 공간 내 움직임이 있으므로
여기 왼쪽 하단에 있는 여러 생리적 변수의 조절은 채집과 관련된
차단 항상성
설정점 및 운동 명령의 통합입니다.
여기에는 다음과 같은 베이지안
시각화가 있습니다.  이전의 사후
가능성 및 추론의 이 양방향
관계와 이전의
역학 모델에 대해 두
밀도에 대한 이야기 ​​그리고 마지막으로 이것은 우리가 바닥으로 가는 것으로 설명하는 개념에 도달하는
또 다른 체온 포도당
모델링 접근법
입니다.
대리석이
특정 구역에서 대부분의 시간을
보내도록
이
냅킨의 모양을 디자인하거나 진화시키거나 선택할 수 있는 그릇  등등
잘 추가할 수 있는 것은 무엇이든 제 생각에 섹션 2는 기본적으로
o
일종의
인식 가능한 유한 한계와
그 한계 내에서
의 가변성에 의존하는 연속성 요소
가 있는 모든 종류의 예측 성능을 수행하고 있습니다.  일종의 2가지 요인
상황에서 이런 신호가 발생
하고 그들은 배럴 반사와 글루카곤 문제의 몇 가지 예를 지적했습니다.
이 두 가지 예의 복잡성
을 유지
하려는 측면에서 유지하는 것은
이러한 용량 곡선을 살펴보기 시작할 수 있게 해주는
것입니다. 좋습니다.  장의 요약 중
이 섹션
에서는 공학
제어 이론의 개념을 소개한 다음
생명 과학에서의 응용을 검토합니다.
여기에는 생리학 섹션 3.1 골격
운동 운동 섹션 3.2 및 의사
결정 섹션 3.3이 포함됩니다. 섹션 3.4는
미래의 차단 상태를
현재의 움직임에 연결
합니다. 알로스테틱 조절을 항상성 조절보다 더 에너지 효율적으로 만드는 요소를 조명
다음 섹션 4는
생리학에서 사용되는 제어 설명을 기반으로 합니다.
차단이 어떻게 allostasis를 지원하는지 제안하기 위해
여기
에서 슬라이드의 모든 내용을 읽지는 않겠지만 이것은 생리학에
대한 섹션 3.1 제어 이론
에서 가져온 것입니다.
네, 컨트롤러
가 잘 작동하려면 컨트롤러가
플랜트의 예상되는 동작의 일종의 복사 또는 미러를 포함해야 합니다. 이를
내부 모델
제어 이론가라고 하는
구동 시스템이 플랜트 및 원하는
궤적 참조  궤적
과
이런 종류의 음에 대한 흥미로운 토론이 있습니다.
제어 이론의 실
그림 4
그래서 그림 4는
모델 기반 제어 시스템의 기능 블록 다이어그램입니다
. 주황색의 플랜트는
모션 또는 기타 동작이
제어
되는 개체 또는 시스템 컨트롤러 보라색은 신호를
합니다.
예상 결과 예측에
노란색 실선 화살표를 노란색으로 상태
추정기에 신호를 보내는 식으로 사람들은
이 수치에 대해 나머지 부분
을 읽을 수 있습니다.
모델의 다른 부분에 대해
사람들이 보고
두 가지가 어떻게 잘 맞는지 실시간으로 확인할 수 있도록
합니다. 미래에 대해 그렇게 할 것이며
이는 라이브 스트림에서 이전 토론을 취소하거나 기억할 것입니다.
23 숙련된 수행과
상호작용주의 및 지시주의 및
모터 플랜트 등에 대해 생각하는 방법
오른쪽
섹션 3.2 신체 이동
참조 제어 가설 그래서
참조 제어 가설
제공된 인용은 Feldman 2015
및 latash 2021
이었고 참조 제어 가설
은 척수의 낮은 수준 반사에 대한 참조 궤적을 처방하는 뇌의 상위 수준 컨트롤러가 있는 컨트롤러 계층의 관점에서 골격 운동 시스템을 설명
합니다.  그런 다음 반사
는 구심성 고유수용기 뉴런에 의해 신호를 받은 근육의 실제 길이
를 뇌에서 보낸 기준 길이
와 비교하고 근육을 수축하여
두 가지가 일치하도록 합니다. 그래서 여기
에 Feldman의 2015년 책 목차의 상단 부분이 있습니다.
행동과 인식의 참조 제어 및
라이프 리뷰 2021의 latash 논문
이러한 유형의 접근 방식에 대한 일부 그래픽이 포함된
외국
현실 세계에서 이 슬라이드로 시작할 수 있습니다.
그들은 여기
에서 일종의 과적합으로 비난 받고 싶지 않기 때문에
모터 제어를 시작하십시오.  실험은 운동 제어
의 실제 구조와 제한적으로
만 중첩되므로 도달 행동에 대한 제한 중첩만 실험
자는 참가자에게 도달 과제를 처방하는 실험자를 포함합니다
뇌는 구체적으로
실험자의 지시를 따르는
것이 아니라 자신의 신체를 조절하는 기능을
합니다  중추 신경계의 실제 조직은
신체의 운동 기능 움직임을 내부에서 볼 때 더 잘 발생합니다. 즉, 신체
의 체성 운동 경로 서지 조절
예를 들어 Dr 값이 있는 게임에서
예기치 않게 딱딱
하거나 날카로운 블록을 밟거나 밟는 경우  당신은 일반적으로
그것을 밟은 자신을 의도적으로 찌르지 않습니다.
그래서 나는 지금 내 발을 통과하고 싶었습니다.
왜냐하면 내 초점은 여전히
내 자세를 안정화시키는
것입니다.
조직 손상은
다음 변명을 위해 무엇을 할지 결정해야 합니다.  e
자신이 당신의 발을 간호
하거나 그 고통을 겪으
면서 그들이 말하는 것을 제한하려고 한다는 사실
이 이 목표 부분이
좋은 것으로 적용될 수 있는 정도
라고 생각합니다.
명령 시스템 또는 제어 시스템
과 요구 시스템 사이의 관계는 다음과
같습니다. 신체
가 경미한 저체온증에 걸리기 시작
하고 뇌가 올바르게 기능하지 않는다는 것을 사람들이 알고 있는 경우
음
예를 들어
음 난 Slurpee 두통이 있고
당신은 Slurpee를 내려놓고
술을 마시지 않는 것을 어떻게 구별합니까?
최소한
우리에게는 버튼이 계속 움직이지 않도록 계속해서 움직이지 않도록 하세요.
모두 함께 멈추는 것을 피하는 것입니다. 이는
본질적으로 죽음입니다.
당신의
두뇌가 죽었다면 당신은 죽은 것이지만 당신의
손이 죽었거나 당신이 여전히
살아 있다면
명령 센터 결과와 수요
센터 결과 사이의 명확한 구별이 용어에서 의미하는 바가 무엇인지에 대한 논쟁에 들어가지 않고
네, 가장 중요한
상황에서 생존을 유지하기 위해 자동으로 하는 일이 있습니다.
그리고 그것은
당신의 것과 같지 않습니다.
당신의 손에는 두뇌가 있지만
단순히 돌아
다니는 것일 수도 있습니다.  예를 들어 누군가가 당신을 구출할 때까지 충분히 오랫동안 당신을 살릴 수 있습니다.
그래서 그것이 혼란스러운지
아닌지 모르겠지만 화해가 있다고 생각합니다.
새로운 새로운 응답이 당신을 인계하고 당신을
살아 있게 하기 위해 명령된 시간을 포기하는 능력이며 당신은
명령 센터에서 그렇게 하는 방법을 반드시 알지 못할 수도
있으므로 우리는'  나는
그것에 대해 저자와 이야기해야 할 것입니다 왜냐하면 이것들은
제가 약간의 생리학적 배경을 가지고 있기 때문에 가지고 있는 질문이기 때문에
이러한 극단적인 상황에 대해 궁금합니다.
나중에 그것에 대해 이야기하겠습니다. 인체 공학에 대해 이야기하는 스크린샷
을 원하는 사람들을 위해 3개의 3개에서
더 많은 인용문을 작성합니다.
이는 부록 B에서 다루지 않을
것입니다.
어 그래서
실험을 위한 기능적 블록 다이어그램 실험적
심리학자 운동 제어에 대한 작업 지향 보기
다이어그램은 개념적 수준에서 형식적 논리 구조를 보여줍니다
. 상자와
화살표는 그림 4
와 대조적으로 뇌 또는 신경계의 해부학에 매핑되지 않습니다
다이어그램은 골격 운동
뇌
와 말초 신장 반사
컨트롤러를 구분하고 감각 상태
추정기 뇌와 말초를 구분합니다.  감각
기관 감각 표면 감각
표면 다이어그램은
심리학
실험에서 실험자가 참가자
에게 행동에 대한 작업을 처방
하여 외부성이
있고 참가자의 뇌
가 행동을 달성하기 위한 제어 시스템으로 작용한다는 점에 주목해야 하는 중요한 공학적 관점을 보여줍니다.
따라서 신체를 유지하는 규정된 행동 시스템은
신체를 움직이는 시스템에
봉사하고 차례로 규정된
행동에 봉사하므로
규범적 외부성에 다시 초점
을
맞춥니다.
그림 5와 대조적으로 알로스타시스의 이 다이어그램은
신체와
실험자가 원하는 작업 행동의
자율적 조절을 위해 설계된 폐쇄 루프 제어 시스템을 보여줍니다.
인테리어 리셉션  ive 상태 추정기
는 추정치를 업데이트하기 위해 예측 오류를 수신
합니다. 업데이트된 추정치는
방문자 모터 컨트롤러에 대한 참조 신호로 발행됩니다.
이 다이어그램은 형식적
논리적 구조를 보여줍니다. 개념적 수준
묘사된 가설
은 Bear 2017의 추론된 해부학적 구조에 의해 제한됩니다.
그러나 상자와 화살표는
반복을 매핑하지 않습니다. 뇌 또는 신경계의 해부학에 일대일로 매핑하지 마십시오.
좋습니다.
여기에서 차이점을 강조하기
위해 왼쪽은 거의
교육
주의자 배열과 비슷하며 이것이
실험 심리학자입니다.
우리가 작업에 대한 의사 코드를 작성하는 것과 같은 이
작업에 대해 생각합니다. 심장 박동수를 이
범위 내로 유지하고 의식적 행동과 스트레칭 또는 더 많은 것을 할 수
있는지 여부를 골격 운동 시스템과 함께 의사 결정을 하고 무의식적
으로 행동합니다.  차단
하는 신체 또는 외부 세계의 생리학
ve 상태 추정기는 골격 운동 결정
의 원하는 구현과 정렬됩니다.
대조적으로 작업 지시의 역할은
이 제어 이론 보기
에서 명령으로 할당량 추정기로 대체되며 매우 유사한 세트를 통해 공급됩니다.
오른쪽에 있지만 여기에는 실제로 스칼라
모터 결정 컨트롤러와 대조적으로 내장 운동 결정 컨트롤러
가 있습니다.
왜냐하면 이것은
왼쪽 버튼이나 오른쪽
버튼을 선택하는 것과 같이 더 초점을 맞추고 있고 그림 6은 배럴의 종류에 더 집중하기 때문입니다
.  반사
제어 이론 보기 그러나 그것은 또한
일반화합니다
저것은 또 다른 보기라고 생각합니다
섹션 4 allostasis 궤적
추적 확률론적 최적 제어
이 섹션에서는
allostatic 의사 결정의 형식 모델을 설명합니다
allostatic 경로 통합 제어 apic
모델
apic에는 간단한 아이디어가 있습니다
지각 개념이 보의 내부 모델 역할을 하는 것처럼 핵심
dy의 감각 표면
작용 개념
은 잠재적인 행동 및
예측된 결과의 내부 모델로도 사용됩니다.
섹션 4.1
은 수학적 형식에서 SOC 목적 함수를 구동합니다.
섹션 2는
용량 곡선
을 나타내고 섹션 4.2는
이 정점 모델을 플러싱하는
것으로 설명됩니다.  4.1
용량 곡선을
목적 함수
로 변환
위의 1 및 그림 1과 같은 주어진 용량 곡선
은 세로 축의 최대값
이므로 최대 y 값으로 나누어
범위로 정규화할 수 있습니다.  0
과 1 사이. 일단 이런 식으로 정규화되면 확률 이론에서
누적 분포 함수로 해석될 수 있습니다.
이것은 정확히 사실 정확히 정확히 사실입니다.
srinivasan Laughlin과 dubs
가 망막
뉴런과 파리의 발화를 예측 코딩의 한 형태로 해석하기 위해 한 일입니다.
CDF 누적
분포 함수의
도함수는 확률을 산출합니다.  밀도 밀도 함수 PDF
를 사용하여 CDF의 파생물이 PDF를 제공합니다.
이것은
수직 축의 높이
가 PDF의 가능성에 해당
하지만 용량 곡선에서 파생된 PDF의
경우 상대적
응답성을 나타내는 확률 분포를 나타내는 보다 친숙한 방법입니다.  섭동에 대해 우리
는 그러한 분포를 참조
분포라고 부를
것이므로
이것은 확률 밀도
함수인 PDF와 CDF 누적 분포
함수 사이의 통계적 분포의 변환입니다.
누군가에게는 매우 친숙할 수도 있고 누군가
에게는 완전히 새 것일 수도 있으므로
괜찮습니다.  바라건대 이것은 둘
사이의 관계를 고려하는 데 여전히 유용
하므로 여기 이 세 이미지의 왼쪽에
있는 PDF
는 확률 분포를 나타내는 보다 친숙한 방법입니다.
우리는
이것이 균일 분포라고 말할
수 있습니다.
6면체 주사위의 각 결과
또는 대략 가우스 종 곡선
상황에서  h 이 두 개의 중간
및 오른쪽 이미지는 모두
종형 곡선의 PDF를 보여줍니다. 종형
곡선이므로 PDF가 가장 친숙한
것입니다. 균일 분포는
PDF의 평평한 선과 같습니다. 종형 곡선은 PDF의 종형 곡선
과 같습니다.
그러나 점근적으로만 최대값과 최소값을 알고 있기 때문에
기본적으로 함수가 해당 분포를 지원할 수 있는 만큼 낮게 시작하는 누적 분포 함수를 만들 수
있으며 누적적으로 누적
되므로 질문에 답하는 데 유용합니다.
2/3인
4, 3, 2 또는 1
을 얻을 확률 또는 2 표준 편차와 같이 2 미만의 z-점수를 얻을 확률은 얼마
입니까? 곡선의 일부가
PDF에서 해당 z-점수 아래에 있는 비율
이 CDF의 한 지점을 빠르게 조회
하여 해결할 수 있습니다
. PDF와 CDF 사이의 관계
는
주사위를 굴리거나 다음과 같이 평가하는 것과 같이 다시 익숙한
교실의 높이는
앞에서 논의한 용량 곡선에서 최대화
될 때 이 최대 제어 지점에 있는 분포로 이동할 수
있으므로 여기에서 그림 2의 CDF
가 도함수를 얻은 다음
어 이런 종류의 음수가 있는 PDF가 됩니다.
곡선 모양
이며 이것이이 주황색 선이 최대화되어 암시 된 것입니다
주황색 선이 최대화
된이
종 모양의이 곡선의 최고점이지만 고전적인
벨크로는 아니지만 산입니다.
어느 쪽인지 알 수있는 하나의 봉우리입니다  우리
는 tedorov 2006의 tedorov 2006의 관행을 따르고 있습니다. PDF 자체가
아닌 목적 함수로 PDF의 로그를 사용
하면 작동점이 계속해서
로컬 최대값으로 나타납니다.  이득
은 작동점에서 멀어지는 이동 비용을 결정하고 작동점
으로 이동하는 값은 그림 8
에서 목적 함수 log de를 보여줍니다.
원래 배럴
반사 용량 곡선에 해당하는 nsity
그림 9는
세 가지를 모두 나란히 표시하여 다양한 형태의 용량 곡선 사이의 관계를 더욱 명확하게
하므로
그림의 왼쪽 상단에 있는 정말 멋진 그림
은 반사가 있는 그림입니다.
CDF로 해석될 때 혈압을 조절하기 위해 전화를 걸거나 줄이면
잔차를 계산하는 대신 최대화할 수 있는 단일 피크
가 됩니다. 이 곡선의 모양은
계산적으로 최적화하기에 약간 더 좋습니다.
거꾸로
깔때기 모양
이
아니라 더 부드러운 그릇
처럼 만들면 왜 이 로그 단계가
중요합니까 아니면 중요하지만 다음과 같이 말하면 충분합니다
.  이것은
S자형
저글링 행위
를 등산
테이블로 전환할 수 있는 큰 움직임이라는 것을 하나는 몇 가지 주요
테이블을 요약하고 하나는 몇 가지 주요 표기를 요약합니다
우리는 우리의 그래픽 모델
이 뇌의 해부학적 구조를 정확하게
포착한다고 주장하지 않습니다. 시간 척도
계층 전반에 걸쳐 참조 기반 감각 운동 제어를 포착
합니다. 표에서 두뇌 변수와 공유되는 단일 기능
방정식 5와 6은
즉각적인 포착 속도
에 대한 것입니다.  점 1.2
섹션 4.2에서 토론
하는 것도 좋을 것입니다. 최적의 먹이 찾기 이론이 제안하는
allostatic 제어를 위한 기능적 형태를 제안합니다.
최적의 먹이 찾기에
대해 추가하고 싶은 것이 있습니까? 저자와 이야기하고 싶습니다.
그것이 의미하는 바가 무엇인지
알 수 있습니다. 방정식
전체 캡처 속도
섹션 4.3 피드백 또는
생성 작업을 통한 피드포워드 제어 개념입니다.
여기에 몇 가지 형식론이 더 있습니다. 이것은
실험
심리학자 프레임워크
가 아니라 제어 이론
프레임워크 내에 있습니다.  왼쪽 섹션의 allostatic 용량
추정기
4.3
방정식 10 방정식 11.
더 많은 변수
stoc  앞서 언급한 성급한 최적 제어 SOC
.
그림 10. 여기에서 신경 계층에 대한 경험적 질문을 다루지 않고 각 수준에서 다중 시간 척도 및 참조 분포를 캡처
하는 계층적 생성 모델을 논의하는 것이 좋을 것입니다.
여기서 우리는
L이 동일한 모델을 사용합니다.
그림 6과 일치하는 네 가지 모델
은 이러한 노드 중 일부가 의미하는 바를 정의
하지만 y축은 시간 척도를 증가
하므로 아마도 더 높은 곳에서는 더 느려질 수
있으며 오른쪽은 시간의 흐름
이므로 이것이 무엇에 대해 생각하게 하거나 무엇을 생각하게 합니까
?  우리가 이 우물에 대한 해석에 접근할 수 있는 방법처럼
저는 똑똑한 Apple을 하려는 것이 아닙니다.
그러나 L4가
제공하는
정보가 꽤 있다는
것이 흥미롭습니다.
4개 이상의 레벨이 있지만
그들은 저를 위해 그것들에 집중하기를 원합니다
제 뇌가 가는 곳은 괜찮습니다. 그래서
우리는 물을 얻었습니다.
곡물을 얻었고
그것은
꽤 좋은 제품을 만들 수 있으므로
주스 또는 무엇이든 추가할 수 있지만
네 가지 기본 재료를 얻었
으므로 시간이 지남에 따라
그것이 가능하게 하는 것은 다시 그들에게 좋을 것입니다.
그것을 분리하는 이유는 이것에서도 많은 것을 정확히 파악할 수 있을 만큼 충분하다고 생각하기 때문입니다.
4.4
생성적 작업 개념을 통한 피드백 제어
여전히 방정식 13이 있습니다. 방정식 14. 그런 다음
예측 처리
및 활성에 익숙한 멋진 인용 독자  추론
은 위의 방정식 14의 형식을 인식합니다.
음의 자유 에너지 또는 변동
하한으로 토론을 위한 몇 가지
인용 참조 일반적으로 목표는 몇 가지 등가 방식
으로 작성 및 해석될 수 있으므로
각각
은 고유한 직관
을 가질 수 있습니다.  신경 처리 과정에서 이러한 특정 발산을 최소화하는 계산 및
열역학적 효율성
을 위해
lable 증거는 움직임의
피드백 수정에 페널티를 주기 위한 다른 더 복잡한 정보 발산을 배제하지
않으므로
예상되는
자유 에너지
가 있고 예상되는 미래의 자유 에너지가 있는 것처럼 다른 하한 변동 하한 음의 자유 에너지가 존재
하는 방식이 매우 흥미롭습니다.  이러한 변형 및 각
에너지
는 교과서의 방정식 2.6과 같이 다르게 분해될 수
있으므로
처음에 어떻게
이러한 종류가 풍부하게 수렴했는지
, 그리고 자유 에너지 원리
와 왜 그러한 공명을 가져야 하는지 보는
것은 흥미로울 것입니다.  즉
, 이러한 에너지 경계의 서로 다른 분할이 어떻게 우리가 생존하는 시스템에 대해 생각하는 데 도움이 될 수 있습니까?
저는 여기에 다니엘을 추가하겠습니다.
나는 그들이 이것을 통과
하는 일종의 잠금 단계
방식에 대해 실제로 어려움을 겪지
않았지만  우리가 방정식 13에 도달하고 방정식 15와 16으로 이동하자마자
나보다 더 똑똑한 누군가가
그 점프를 정말 간단한 용어로 설명할 수 있어야 할 것입니다.
왜냐하면
비록 내가 그것을 여러 번 읽었음에도 불구하고
나는 여전히 그것이 어떻게 작동하는지 정확히 확신하지 못
하기 때문에 다시 저자
들은 그들의 가장 부드러운 장갑을 가져오고 싶어할 것입니다.
왜냐하면 제가 핸드헬드가 필요하기 때문입니다.
예,
섹션 4.4에 동의했습니다. 여전히 여기에 방정식 15가 있습니다.
섹션 4.4에는 방정식 16이 있습니다.
멋진
J
방정식 14.
최적 피드백 컨트롤러 단독
방정식 15에 대한 해석적 표현을 Bellman 방정식
방정식 12에 대입하면 방정식 16이 생성됩니다.
이제 방정식의 다루기 힘든 재귀 항이 무엇인지
알아보겠습니다.  용어는
계산적으로 다루기 쉬운 문제를 더 많이 생성
합니다. 정보 Fancy
J의 Divergence 용어는 차이로 정확하게 기록될 수 있기 때문에 그러한 방식으로 제공합니다.
Q star star sub Phi 아래에서 다루기 힘든 최대값
과 미리 계획된 작업에서 보다 다루기 쉬운 부드러운 최대값 사이의
개념
기호 방정식 17. 꽤 흥미롭습니다.
um s 방정식 17에서 21
다음 마지막 섹션 섹션 5에
대한 토론
이 도움이 될 수 있습니다.  오늘은 13세
에서 17세, 그리고 18세 19세와 20세
입니다. 스케일 특정 또는 스케일 친화적 음 세부사항과 함께 스케일 자유 형식의 일부를 조합
할 수 있는 방법입니다.  그것을 명확히 하려고
하는 것은 훌륭한
질문
이고 그래서 당신은 글로벌에 대해 이야기
하고 나는 그들이 그것을 철자할 수 있어야 한다고 생각합니다. 그리고 제 생각에는
그렇습니다. 하지만
다시 저는
저입니다. 갑자기 일이
저를 위해 도랑에 빠졌습니다
여기에 내가
초기 섹션에서 모험을 하고 싶은
것이 있습니다. 항상성과 항상성의 대조가
있으며, 뇌 신경 해부학 및 기능의 특정 분산 모델에서 보상 시스템이 더 이상 필요하지 않은 방법에 대해 설명합니다.
그래서 저는 다음
형식
이 보상 극대화에 자주 사용되는 Bellman 방정식과 같은 최적 및 최적화 프레임워크에서 증강 목표를 최적으로 대체한다고 생각합니다.
얼마나 많은 보상이 쌓이는지에
따라 시간이 지남에 따라 호기심 등이 어느 정도 가치가 있을 것입니다.
Horizon
은 높이 측면에서 보상을 용이하게 한다고 생각
했지만 여기에서는 pdfcdf 관계를 사용하여
최적의 기동성 극대화와 같은 방향으로 이동하는 것을 보고 있습니다.
CDF 오른쪽 중간 지점으로 Divergence를 줄이려고 시도하는 대신
로그 PDF를 최대화하는 측면에서 응답성을 최대화합니다.
그래서 그것이 다루기 쉬운 증강 um 보상 기능이라고 생각합니다.
그런 다음
해당 기능과 방법을 지정하는 작업이 남아 있습니다.
아마도
괜찮게 행동
하면 섹션 5 토론
차단이 행동을 안정시키고
알을 구성합니다.  손실된 참조
사람들은 인용문을 볼 수 있습니다 여기에 요약할 수 있는 것은 무엇이든
좋습니다 5.1 뇌를
알로스테틱 최적 컨트롤러로 보기
알로스테틱 경로 적분 제어
섹션 4의 apic 모델은 여러 특정 가설을 암시합니다.
활성 추론 모델이 있는 공유 모델링 선택의 수는
아마도 apic이 일종의 활성 추론 모델로 간주되기에 충분할
것이고, 그런 다음 엄밀한 의미
에서 활성 추론 모델과 공유되는 몇 가지 다른 기능(
있는 경우)
및 관련
모델링 노력 추가
할 사항 없음  아니오 그들은 여기에서 꽤 명확하게 철자합니다
당신은 이 권리를 통해 읽고 싶어
합니다 5.1은 apic 모델 5.2에 대한 몇 가지 예측
과 몇 가지 대조를 제공합니다.
제어 이론의 렌즈를 통해 신체와 두뇌
그림 6은 본능적 감각 데이터
상승 효과를 보여줍니다  X 구심성
인터셉티브 예측 오류
가 되기 위해 설명하시겠습니까? br  즉
사람들이
용어집에서 설명할 수 있기 때문에 X 풍요가 의미하는 바는
기본적으로 작동 신호에 대한 명백한 신호이기
때문입니다. 거기에 약간의
재귀
가 있습니다. 거기에 무엇이든 추가하고 싶은 것
음
구심성이 무엇인지 강조하기 위한 차이점이 보입니다  구심
성은 신경을 위해 안쪽으로 또는 무언가를 향해 전도하거나 전도
하고 있습니다. 중추 신경계
혈관을 위한 기관이 제대로 공급
되고 음
정확한 노력을 어떻게 구별할 수 있습니까?
그 명백한 신호의 축적이
흥미롭다는 점에서
내가 빼낸 것입니다. 당신이 틀렸다고 생각합니다. 그것이 내가
5개의 차단 및 용량
곡선을 취한 것입니다.
반응은 가장 놀라운 자극을 위해 예약되어 있습니다.
Barrett 2017의 제안
및 제안 및 2013년 dwark의 발견에 따르면 특정
주변 요격기와 인간
은 지속적인 자극 하에서 작동 발사 속도를 0으로
줄입니다.
무언가
가 덜 자주 바뀌는
모델이 있고 이 apic 모델에서 필수적인 응답
성의 증가는 긍정적으로 행동 궤적을 강화하는 보상으로 기능할 수 있는
반면 응답성의 감소
는 비용으로 부정적으로 기능할 수 있다는 가설을 세웠습니다.
행동 궤적
을 강화하여 무한한 시간 동안 옵션을 열어 두는
것 Horizon은
비즈니스를 계속 유지하거나 생리학을 제한적으로 유지하는 것과 같습니다.
예
, USD 또는 칼로리의 양을
바로 최대화하는 대신 외부 연속성을 유지하는 것이 아니라
범위 및 궤적에 대한 놀라움을 줄이거나 제한하는 것과 같습니다.
전략이
아닌  5.3 차단 및 용량 곡선을 생성하기 위해 여기에 언급된 대로 이 모델에서
5.4 결론 마침내
아마추어
피구 선수
에게 돌아가
겠습니다.  다루기 쉬운
것은 우리가 이전에 이야기한 부록 B
에어컨
이지만 멋진 주제이므로 이 부록을 건너뛰고
저자와 논의하기를 바랍니다. 그러면
방정식 B의 방정식이
처방을 공식화하고  제어
는 자유 에너지 원리로 이어집니다.
부록 B 부록 C에서 더 많은 것 Apic 모델
유도 세부 사항
방정식
C 0.1.2 최적 값
함수 및 전이의 완전한 유도 역학 더 많은
방정식
값에 대한 경로 적분 형식
은 기술에 이름을 부여합니다.  경로 적분
제어 등 일종의 마무리
메모  이것이
베이지안 역학 및 베이지안 역학의 세 가지 측면 중
가장 오른쪽에 있는 경로 공식화와 어떻게 연결되는지, 그리고
잠재적으로
완전히 다른 시작점
과 다른
접근 방식 및 제약 조건에서 오는 방법에 대해
일부 유사한 기능
이 발생하여 정점에서 강조 표시되었는지 궁금
했습니다.
또한
경로 형식화에서 베이지안 역학에 대해 강조 표시되고 관련이
있으며 매핑되지 않은 벤 다이어그램과 같은 것이
있을 수 있습니다. 우연히든 의도적으로든 간에
마지막 라이브 스트림에 대한 몇 가지 유사점과 차이점
이 있습니다.  이 논문
은 흥미롭습니다. 당신이 끝내고
자 하는 것은 무엇이든 잘 동의
했습니다. 모델링과 내부 모델링에서 모드를 볼 수 있다는 아이디어와
그 둘 중 하나를
다시 조정할 수 있다는 아이디어는 최소한 2가지 정도로 생각합니다.
기타 위험 관리 또는 위험 최소화
행사로 제한 전략
또는 옵션 생성  확장 또는
확장 전략은 저자
와 이야기하기에 정말 흥미로운 것이 될 것입니다.
왜냐하면 형식주의 13과 모든 것 사이의 점프를 지나갈 때까지 apic 모델이 두 영역에서 작동
하는지 여부를 실제로 파악할 수 없기 때문입니다.
17 18 19에서 20까지입니다.
하지만 그것에 대한 설명
과 어, 그리고 부드러운 자극으로 그것이 우리가 생리적 존재인
것처럼 보일 때 그것이 어떻게 작동하는지 알아내는 것은 흥미로울 것입니다.
위험 관리와 옵션 옵션
생성기 옵션 확장 모두를 저글링할
수 있으므로 여기에서 실제로 매우 흥분
됩니다.
allostatic 관점에서 다음 내기
내가 말했듯이
그 점프가 어떻게 작동하는지 더 잘 이해할 수 있다면 그것은
정말 흥미 진진하다고 생각합니다.
무한 호라이즌에 대한 최고의 생리학적 결정
은 좋은 질문입니다. 예
, Eternal은
이제 존재
하고 음 또한
어떤 종류의 데이터
가 이러한 유형의 모델과 관련이 있는지와 같이 조금 더 일상적인 것과 같이
이미 존재하는 데이터입니다.
사람들
은 희소 데이터 세트에서 많은 것을 외삽할 수
있거나 모델 매개변수
에 대한 좋은 통계적 확신을 얻고
중요하지 않은 결과를 추출하기 위해 많은 복제가 필요
하며 이
기술 또는 접근 방식이 사용되는 곳입니다.  또는
어디에서 사용할 수 있습니까? 잘 이야기
할 수 있는 흥미로운 것들이 많이
있습니다. 모든 준비와
도움에 감사드립니다. Dean과
1점
에서 뵙겠습니다.